THE REST OF US WOULD BE HAPPY TO
BUY SLIGHTLY MORE EXPENSIVE
LETTUCE.
JEFF SESSIONS WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
HE IS RUNNING TO REENTER THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
HE RECENTLY MADE THE SUGGESTION.
HOW ABOUT A NATIONWIDE
MORATORIUM ON IMMIGRATION UNTIL
AMERICANS ON EMPLOYMENT RATE HAS
RECOVERED FROM THIS DISASTER?
JEFF SESSIONS JOINS US.
SENATOR, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
TELL US YOUR PROPOSAL.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE I DIDN’T
MISSTATE IT.
>> WE HAVE ABOUT 1.4 MILLION
PEOPLE THAT COME TO THIS COUNTRY
EVERY YEAR TO TAKE JOBS.
WE JUST ANNOUNCED TODAY
5 MILLION MORE PEOPLE ON THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RULE, THAT’S 22 MIL
NOW.
THERE IS NO DOUBT IT’S IN THE
INTEREST OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
EVERY ONE OF THOSE UNEMPLOYED
AMERICANS THE JOBS FIRST.
I MEAN, IT’S PSYCHOLOGICALLY
DEVASTATING TO A PERSON NOT TO
HAVE WORK.
IT UNDERMINES THEIR WELL-BEING
AND FAMILY.
IN ADDITION, WE HAVE TO HELP
THEM FINANCIALLY IF THEY ARE
UNEMPLOYED.
WHETHER IT’S MEDICAID, MEDICARE,
FOOD STAMPS, UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE.
SO WHY BRING IN FOREIGN WORKERS
TO TAKE THOSE JOBS WHEN WE
SHOULD DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE,
AS YOU SUGGESTED, TO GET
AMERICAN WORKERS THAT ARE
UNEMPLOYED IN THOSE JOBS.
>> Tucker: THAT IS SUCH AN
OBVIOUS POINT, AND I SHOULD NOTE
THAT YOU ARE EMPLOYING THE MOST
BASIC ECONOMIC PRINCIPLE OF ALL,
SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
TIGHTER LABOR MARKET MEANS
HIGHER WAGES.
WHO COULD POSSIBLY OBJECT TO
THAT?
DO MOST AMERICANS AGREE WITH
YOU, DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK MOST AMERICANS TO
AGREE WITH ME.
I THINK THE POLL IS A MOST 90%
THAT IF THERE IS A CHOICE
BETWEEN WHO SHOULD GET A JOB,
THE AMERICANS SHOULD GET THE JOB
OVER A FOREIGNER.
GIVE ME A BREAK.
HOW SIMPLE IS THAT?
WHO DO WE OWE OUR RESPONSIBILITY
TO, AS GOVERNMENT AND PUBLIC
OFFICIALS?
IT’S TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
FIRST.
SO THAT’S ABSOLUTELY TRUE.
IF WE DO THIS THING RIGHT, WE
CAN MINIMIZE THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE THAT HAVE PROLONGED
UNEMPLOYMENT.
IF IT’S A -- IT’S A SCARY TIME.
IT’S VERY SCARY.
WE NEED TO BE VERY ALERT TO THE
DANGERS.
THINK ABOUT A COLLEGE GRADUATE
TODAY, IN MAY WILL BE
GRADUATING.
WHAT KIND OF PROSPECTOR THEY
HAVE?
WE HAVE ALMOST 500,000 TECH
WORKERS THAT COME TO AMERICA.
CAN’T WE FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR KIDS, MAYBE
WITH COLLEGE DEBT, GET THOSE
JOBS FIRST?
BEFORE YOU BRING IN FOREIGNERS.
IT’S JUST THE NATURE OF THE
WORLD TODAY.
WE NEED TO PROTECT OUR OWN.
IT’S THE RATIONAL, MORAL,
RESPONSIBLE THING TO DO.
>> Tucker: THIS COULD BE A
LONG ANSWER.
WE ONLY HAVE A MINUTE LEFT BUT I
HAVE TO ASK YOU SINCE YOU WORKED
IN GOVERNMENT FOR DECADES.
HAVE CLOSE TO 90% OF THE PUBLIC
WANTS SOMETHING TO HAPPEN AND IT
NEVER HAPPENS, FOR MANY YEARS,
IS THIS REALLY A DEMOCRACY?
>> YOU ARE ASKING A FUNDAMENTAL
QUESTION.
THIS IS A TIME, THIS ISSUE AND
OTHERS LIKE IT I REALLY RAISED
TO THE LEVEL THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE.
IT’S NOT DONE SURREPTITIOUSLY
UNDER THE TABLE BY ESTABLISHMENT
POLITICIANS IN BOTH PARTIES,
OFTEN SUPPORTED BY THE LOW-WAGE
AGENDA OF SOME OF THE CORPORATE
POWERS THAT BE.
THAT’S HOW I DEFEATED, LED THE
FIGHT TO DEFEAT THE IMMIGRATION
BILL.
IT TOOK A LONG TIME BUT ONCE THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE UNDERSTOOD THOSE
BILLS, THEY TURNED AGAINST THEM
AND THE POLITICIANS DID.
UNTIL THEY REALLY UNDERSTOOD THE
NATURE OF IT, IT WAS ON THE
PATHWAY TO PASSAGE.
THIS IS A REAL POLITICAL
QUESTION OF IMPORTANCE FOR
AMERICA.
PEOPLE LIKE YOURSELF DO HELP
KEEP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
INFORMED.
>> Tucker: WE ARE TRYING ON